all right good afternoon everyone my
name is Maurice Rabb and I'm here to
talk about my collections framework hand
X
I'm director pedagogy at spantry we're a
boutique software engineering firm based
in Chicago we work on hard problems uh
we work on cool problems uh we are we
hire from time to time if you're
interested in joining us oh that was my
those are my colleagues and these are my
colleagues uh yeah but we'd love to work
on your projects
all right so what is hand ax what's this
pattern language why should we care
uh it's in it's a set of inter related
patterns for thinking about implementing
thinking about and implementing
Collections and programming languages
it's a means of transcending individual
programming languages and becoming a
standard for naming and semantic choices
in the development of collections
design patterns enabled common language
for known but sometimes unnamed
structures in software
my goal with hand ax is to create a
similar lingua Franca for interacting
with collections
and lastly it's my hope that the
framework will influence existing and
future languages
so why does this matter
well collections are a fundamental part
of any language that we use
and most collection Frameworks languages
are very idiosyncratic given that given
that centrality it would seem that
standards are warranted
so why do we need this and what's in it
for you
uh have you ever been bitten by
unexpected Behavior using collections
uh hey have you have uh you ever found
yourself digging through the docks
trying to figure out some obscure
parameter or return type
in mdn yes
uh it shouldn't shouldn't it really be
able shouldn't you really be able to
just infer things from the method names
wouldn't that be nice
uh do you have a hard time remembering
the difference between shift and unshift
uh when jumping between languages you
get Whiplash and want to cry because the
semantics are different
okay so what will I be discussing today
a set of strict conventions for naming
aspects of collections in AKA grips
using Edge oriented thinking and
collections
a method for visually describing
collections
using a domain-specific language for
composing methods
conventions for managing immutability
prototypal property resolution I'll give
a walkthrough of that because it's
necessary to understand how I
dynamically Implement methods on the Fly
based on the behaviors that are inferred
and by the way I'll tell you what these
pretty rocks are about
okay so my language journey I started I
didn't see imperative close to the
machine wonderful but I got exposed to
Small Talk early this wonderful
declarative language uh and then I had
to go on Java and then I had fun in a
JavaScript and then I had to go to Ruby
and then back in typescript and
JavaScript
um but I really want to talk about small
talk because it was the most luxurious
programming experience I've ever had the
the experience of writing code was
living in the debugger you would write a
method and you would call a method and
if the method didn't exist it exists the
debugger would open up and you'd write
it right there and it would save it and
you just keep moving it was amazing I've
not had anything like it since and the
other thing I got spoiled with was this
amazing class hierarchy it just felt
like such a treasure Trove particularly
The Collection classes
rich and well thought out
also I just want to say it's important
for us to know our history Small Talk
was the basis of a lot of stuff that we
use now we take for granted extreme
programming which which launched agile
uh test driven development before there
was jest and junit there was s unit uh
refactoring uh wikis came out of this
community
Small Talk took me to U of I I met Ralph
Johnson through small talking learn more
about design patterns learn the basis of
design patterns being in a pattern
language and learn more about domain
driven design which is a pattern
language for larger software engineering
patterns I'll be talking about a pattern
language shortly
so languages come and go
and we borrow from the past but yet in
our profession we're just rushing
forward all the time we're barely paying
attention to the Past we're not
considering often as we move so quickly
uh the decisions we make how they will
impact the future we can we can say this
generally about stuff we make but I'm
specifically thinking about languages
all languages have warts uh Brenda Nike
is the first to admit it that mistakes
were made uh when you make something in
10 days in a fever dream you're bound to
make some mistakes and he had no idea
when he did this that it was going to
become one of the most important
languages in the world and the basis a
part of a pillar of the internet
don't break the internet
so just talking about some methods real
quick the med the ugly the bad the nasty
I'm going to be talking about slice
splice boy those are hard to say
shift and unshift let's get those out of
the way right now okay
so
shift you taken you take a list
and you pull the first one off
yay and then on shift you take a list
and you jam one on the front upsetting
the other one at the front and the way
you remember this or the way I remember
it is I just dropped the f
and I'll just I'll just leave that as a
gross uh exercise for you
so uh you know just to cut to the chase
in hand X there's none of this nonsense
we have a sensible at first
delete first push becomes add last and
pop becomes
delete last okay and by the way when I
have the js on one side and the Hand X
on the other that's when I'm referring
to different languages now it's really
easy for us to criticize what's done
like what were they thinking
um but I I really think it's important
for us to embody
um a sense of gratitude and humility
um many people in open source are
working on things that are labors of
Love uh Eric Evan
chaplicky he gave a great talk in 2018
here talking about this you know
programming is hard and I just think we
need a spirit of generosity we can be
critical and be kind
it's hard to predict the future
sometimes we wish we could go back in
time and rename a method or change the
signature of semantics and it's hard
sometimes we need to add a new method
and we really want it but the name's
already taken or classical semantics
that were already there
Ford compatibility is a lot harder than
backward compatibility
you know why can't we have nice things
you know I think we all have Stockholm
syndrome a bit the the worst enemy of a
better solution is our existing
complacency with what's good enough now
so but I say we can do better
our software and tools are the home we
live in let's make them as nice as we
possibly can
all right so let's cut to a pattern
range or pattern languages
a set of interconnected patterns that
contribute to a larger hole
each pattern describes a problem in a
solution space
The observed problems and solutions come
from the wild like what have we observed
people doing what have we observed in
architecture in a pattern language for
example together they create a state of
Enlightenment for the domain at least we
hope so and uh Christopher Alexander of
a pattern language frame calls this
equality With No Name uh I like to call
it the Quan
uh now as a caveat I think hand X
satisfies most of these but the third
one it meets the standard a little
uneven so I just beg your Indulgence
all right so a pattern language what's
this this is the seminal work by
Christopher Alexander it was super
influential in the software engineering
community it has 100 253 patterns of
various scales that are interconnected
that create a social architectural
language uh one of my favorite ones is
this 125 stair seating we do this in
front of the is it the Stifler theater
is that how you say it
Stifler Stifler thank you we would sit
out there at lunch and and watch the
people uh this is something that we see
in lovely public spaces
all right so I'm going to proceed moving
forward I'm going to identify some
challenges we're going to use JavaScript
as a basis and I'm going to talk about
patterns and I may do them in reverse
order or forward order but I'll try to
bring you along okay but first let's do
a dissection of some of what JavaScript
does let's look at the core collections
arrays which are ordered strings are
ordered and immutable and only held
characters
sets are no duplicating values and maps
are key value Pairs and so on the right
is how I will be representing these
various structures throughout the The
Talk
um all right so
we have a set which holds values and we
have dictionaries which hold Elements
which are an association of keys and
values and they're unorder
okay let's look at their protocol in
JavaScript it's very small and I just
like to think about unifying what's like
so they both do size they both do four
each they both do clear the same
semantics for them uh the they both do
has and delete and the only difference
between them it has in a set is a value
and has in a dictionary is a key but you
can argue that the uh and by the way I'm
using yellow for values and blue for
keys but you can argue that in a set the
key and the value are one and the same
we use a key to look it up so we can
treat it that way and we can smash these
two together so they have pretty much
have the same protocol which is nice
and this is in theory again and we have
uh Maps can get a value at a key so here
I'm looking at this chili and I I'm also
saying well perhaps we could do the same
thing in sets and so I would get that
um the element at that chili rather the
value at that chili
so we can unify that now with a set a
map you can set a value and so here I
want to set uh the cherries at the
avocado
and I could also argue I could do the
same thing it would just overwrite in a
in a uh set and so that's the result
that we would get and we've unified it
there
and lastly we have ADD so we can add
something to a set we are adding a value
or an element if you prefer
and but the elements of a map are again
these key value pairs so we can add
those as well unify
all right so I just want to talk about
that like this is you know thinking
about the various elements and how they
these grips if you will uh on a
collection now array has a much larger
protocol I'm not going to go into it it
still sparse compared to many but we're
going to talk about position uh you know
the uh the brackets and at and slice
okay so here we have an array
okay we can do absolute positioning
using the uh braces so at three that
index three I'm going to get back at
Chile
and at eight it's off the side I'm going
to get back undefined and if I go the
opposite way I'm off the other side of
the area I'm going to get undefined as
well
and uh not long ago they added uh
relative indexing with at and so we get
the same Behavior Uh with three and
eight as you would expect but the
negatives are a little different we have
a negative three coming off the back end
and that's going to give me broccoli
all right but let's see now let's look
at slice slice is going to take a
section of an array and so here let's
say we're specifying we want to go from
index 2 to 6.
and that's going to give us this
uh sub collection
those four elements right there
and you know what's annoying is you got
to keep track of the inclusivity and
exclusivity of the indices I find it
I've got to look it up all the time I've
been doing JavaScript for how many years
you know a house has gotten bit by this
you know it works for the uh negative
indexing as well this will give us the
exact same
set of results but you know this these
semantics oops these semantics are hard
to remember
so it's challenging to demarcate the
proper starting end of a span using
indices
we need an easier way to address the
proper indexing of an ordered collection
and so remember slice is declared as
start index and end index but what if
instead we say edges
and so here we're looking at indices and
now I'm looking at edges indices edges
we're going to use the fence poses
versus the fence beams and now all of a
sudden this method makes so much more
sense because it's always just going to
be between those fence posts
we call that a span
and the thing that we're spanning over
is a sub again a sub collection
all right I'd like to say you know we
use zero indexing in JavaScript and a
lot of other languages but some use one
and one indexing has its place I'm not
going to get religious about it but any
uh reasonable framework should be able
to handle both of these approaches and
that certainly works the same for uh
spans
uh so that that's our solution I'm going
to jump ahead because I've just stated
what it is all right so I'm Uncle Momo I
love to teach
um
these kinds of problems have happened a
lot in helping neophyte programmers and
Junior developers I taught at U of I at
Columbia College it's taught for a while
at Dev boot camp I have a few students
here uh taught many many students and
now I was at Broad Social Lab at Spanish
now doing some teaching as part of my
job which I love uh I've been doing this
for more than 10 years off and on uh
probably more I've worked with countless
students and Junior engineers and this
is my life's work working and developing
Junior Engineers younger folks and
trying to help them develop a better
mental model of what they are doing if
you have an inconsistent medical model
it inhibits understanding and
collections unfortunately arrive for
this dispense despite their importance
so I'm trying to make this easier for
Lay programmers to have greater
confidence in what they're doing
all right so let's talk about grips now
so we have these Collections and I want
to like do I want to get the index of it
do I want to get a value do I want to
get a key I I I that's this is my way of
talking about these parts and I wanted
to use a term that didn't clash with uh
that was not overloaded in uh Computing
so that's why I'm using this uh so we
use and so you know we were talking
about arrays but now we're going to talk
about lists and instead of sets groups
and dictionaries to avoid naming
conflict because my first implementation
is in JavaScript and I don't want to
confuse the semantics so from now we're
going to be talking about list groups
and sets and so these are the shape of
them and let's go in and talk about the
grips now so I talked about values we
use yellow for values
they all have values
and we have keys in in a list the keys
are the indices in a in a dictionary
there's they're specified and in a group
they're implied
and they are natural pairs between keys
and values they're the natural pair and
elements it's easiest to look at
dictionary first the element is the key
value pair but in a group or a list You
could argue that the value is also an
element and we often use these words
interchangeably when we're talking about
collections but I want to be specific
about them and the natural pair of an
element is an industry particularly in
ordered collections
and I also mentioned Subs which are a
subsection of a collection and air
natural pair is the span for which you
define it of course spans are only for
ordered collections
all right and now we also have the idea
of ordered groups and dictionaries uh we
don't have them in JavaScript but
they're convenient to have some time to
time a a keyed as well as ordered
collection and the grips are shown here
as well so we can use indices to
reference elements in them
all right so challenges
we have these grips as I've defined them
we're we're reclaiming these words key
value indices element Edge span and sub
for a specific meaning
right and also I have a visual language
for talking about collections to be more
explicit uh this description is what
we've just seen now
all right but now let's say we want to
compose methods it's not always easy to
tell from a method name what it does
likewise it's not always possible to do
systematics or signature from its name
its parameters and return values we need
a way for method names to be unambiguous
in communicating what they do and their
method signatures
all right so Hand X has a vocabulary of
nouns we were just talking about them
grips
and we also have prepositions at of over
across Within
and we can modify oh these are locators
I'm sorry we use these as locators in
the in a collection
and we also have determiners which are
qualifiers for
um the grips I want the first value I
want every element
these are naturally paired together
and then lastly we have verbs which are
the commands that we do so if we want to
do some writing as opposed to just
reading I may say at last I want to put
something
and each of these commands has a very
specific meaning I'm not going to go
through all of them in the interest of
time but they all have very defined
semantics about what they mean nothing
more nothing less
okay so accessors don't contain a man
command word so we're going to push them
off we're going to slide these over and
with a accessor we have a
a input grip that gives me an output
grip hey at this indices I want this
element input to Output I have this key
I want to get this value at a particular
value I want to know what key is that we
have input grips and output grips and
and there's an implicit relationship
between what we can expect let's start
looking at these okay so let's look at
at which is the simplest hey I've got a
list I want the veggies at 2 which will
be an avocado okay and this is a natural
relationship again between the industry
and a value hey I want to do a index of
this broccoli what will it be it will be
three
hey I want to do within within is
analogous to slice I want to take a span
and tell me the sub that's added so I
would get this avocado and broccoli in
this case
all right let's look at over and across
I'm going to I'm going to wipe over
across but they do similar things they
take a uh a sub collection and go to a
span it's the inverse of Within so here
we go so I have a this list the same
list I want to get this sub collection
um chili and avocado makes for great
guac
and I would like to know what span is
over it so we see that and and you can
see on the left
how these again how the span and sub are
related
okay so these are the primary
relationships
but you know in theory you should be
able to go from any grip to another I'm
not saying that you should do it but in
theory it should work it's an orthogonal
approach towards gripping
so um again I talked about qualifiers
let's talk about those in some isolation
Okay so we'll talk about uh the uh the
everyone but where I'm Tongue Tied we'll
come back to where all right so first
and last are ordinals we talk about
order with them they assume an ordered
collection
quantifiers oh well and we have forward
and backward for ordinals and
quantifiers are talking about a
multiplicity of things that we like to
reach uh each and every being very
distinct we're in all so like each of
you
all the audience
and uh oops uh well what was let me see
if I can just go back quickly
oh animation
so the distinct ones can be either
internally focused which is every or
externally and I'll give examples of
these to make it plain all right so
let's look at the ordinals first I have
a list good for guac here I'd like to
get the span of the first set of triples
and I'm going from left to right because
it's first uh front to back and so I get
that span one to four likewise I can go
the reverse way oh and by the way I want
to say like with uh with most things
going front to back is the implicit so
we don't necessarily need to say first
but we can if we want to span overworks
just as well as span first
now I can go backward and I'll get the
last triple which is from the span of 8
to 11.
and now let's talk about the uh
multiplicative ones every is good every
is going to look at uh
a plurality of discrete matches
and so here we're going to go from left
to right we'll find one there and then
the next one is there
and but sometimes let's say we want just
not each discrete one we want everyone
we want what all of them
so here we go this will give us all in
case we need it I'm not saying we need
this method but if we do want it we know
how to specify it unambiguously
all right and so these were internally
focused we are iterating over the
receiver object but sometimes you want
to iterate over the parameter so we use
each for that and so in this case hey I
would like to find this triple and I'd
also like to find the guac in the uh
what do we call it the chili and so it
would give me these two results I am
iterating
over the I'm doing the plurality of the
external part
versus the internal so this is describes
the quantifier qualifiers
all right so where let's talk about
where you know and what's you know wait
a minute
um wait wait wait okay wait one name is
cool to rule them all
right
so let's see where where were we okay so
let's say I have a list sometimes you
want to have a condition that defines
what we want
so let's have this list
and I would say hey I want the I want
hey list I want the peppers
so I can say index of where
I can say hey where give me where this
thing is a pepper and it's going to give
me
um
it's going to give me that first pepper
likewise I can go backward I can get the
last pepper
I'm following that conditional
and of course I could do every hey give
me everywhere this conditional is true
and these methods are analogous to find
index fine fine last and interestingly
filter and you know these are okay names
but I would argue that the construction
of the names that I have done this way
are unambiguous
if one uh understands the relationships
of the grips and composability okay so
we effectively have a domain specific
language with these keywords as the
fundamental parts for composing methods
and I squashed them down there to make
some space uh okay so with a uh accessor
we we talked about this quite a bit we
have location qualifier grip possibly a
front grip
and with a Setter we mix an accessor and
a command
and let's look at some of these so let's
say we want at last put
let's see okay so I have this list this
Source list
and I say hey hey sourceless
at your last avocado let's put some
blueberries
and so it finds the last one that value
and it replaces that value
it gives me the result
and what's cool about this is it works
the same with dictionaries as well it
should work the same with
um
with uh groups as well these are
orthogonal for the most part
so I can say hey again give me that
avocado value and there let me replace
it with a
blueberry
and so you know just to look at another
we have within Echo let's add and over a
span I'd like to Echo a value so here I
am looking at the span of zero to three
and I'm placing a carrot at every
element within or rather every value
within and it works just as well on any
type of collection
okay so uh we spoke about the challenge
the solution here is a DSL with strict
semantics
all right so
now one thing you may notice is a Setter
always responds with a changed
collection
so if I have for example a source and I
want to add this eggplant at the end I'm
getting a new resulting
array with the change to it
this is an immutable case
in it answers a copy with the change
that's also immutable now in the uh
mutable case let's say this array is
mutable it's going to change it in place
and return that same thing it's always
returning a a list in this case it'll
always return that the instance or the
same type of the thing and
um
yeah so this is how we do this and this
is known as the command query separation
pattern which was first done in Eiffel
uh Bertrand Meyer moved this forward
it's been used in kqsr uh it's a
well-known pattern and the idea is that
you're either asking an object to tell
me something about itself or I'm
commanding you to do something typically
a mutation on yourself or a a mutation
that's going to create a new copy that
is mutated but yet immutable
so I've just said all this so I'm going
to move on
um so uh
I say mutability is like a spice like
you should lean immutable but mutability
has this place in sandak's immutability
is the norm uh invariably collections
are value objects if you want to think
about it from a domain-driven design
perspective but let's not be dogmatic uh
some data structures prior to cues they
have to be mutable or they don't make
sense sometimes internal state of a uh
uh entity it needs to be mutable and but
it's hidden inside so no one knows what
happens inside me is none of your
business no one touches my liver
uh
all right so but in many language
mutability is the norm
so in this case Small Talk was that way
JavaScript sadly is that way and so when
I do this it is changing in place
and what's interesting though is like
okay if I change in place what am I
returning
well with a small talk I get the thing
out that I put in
okay uh in JavaScript I get out the
length of what I did okay
I mean
how could this happen
you know what's what craziness is this
you know but you know the reason is
because often people look at methods as
an opportunity I certainly have had like
if you're changing State you're like oh
I got this return value I can do
something with it and that's mad
convenient but it's problematic because
it prevents this uh command query uh
pattern from being possible which
defeats immutability
for the most part which sucks
so here we go let's let's go back to the
other here we go a splice where we
started okay this is a strange method
it's mad crazy useful but strange
uh we're going to take a start a delete
count and then possibly many items blah
blah blah
and it remove it Returns the removed
Elements which is convenient I will not
lie okay and slice remember it's kind of
its pair it's like hey I'm not going to
change I'm just going to access between
the start and end Edge I'm calling them
edges by the way that's the only one I
think I encourage you to use them as
well
okay uh it returns this band Element
uh but you know you know come on
all right you know we live with this and
this is the fabric of our life
unfortunately
okay but there's a better way so here we
are going to talk about oh let's look at
supplies for a second okay so here we go
so I have these chilies that I want to
replace from three to two what the hell
is three to two mean three in this case
is that edge okay edges are good and two
is I don't want to go to length forward
you know let me look at slice at least
at least this makes a little more sense
this is three to five okay
all right and so I I'm expecting the
removed part to be equal to this sub
that I've just sliced so we can account
on that and I'm expecting now this array
to be changed and it does what it says
it's going to do but again come on now I
mean how many times have I had to look
this up after leaving JavaScript for a
while
all right so like I said there's a
better way so here we have a list
similar stuff I have a similar sub that
I want to put in I'm going to use a span
and we're going to call this method
within replace within a span I want to
replace
and we get the result we expect but oh
and let me say like if if I want that
what's going to be removed I got to get
out beforehand which I just did because
again we're going to return
the original the original list has to
maintain its Integrity unchanged so we
have to get out the new list the new
change list immutable
as our return value okay so let's see uh
here we go with
okay so yeah one other thing so let's
say you don't feel like
digging the remove thing out or maybe
you don't need it one other way to do it
is every Setter in hand X has this
optional uh Handler where it will give
you the remove thing or the new result
so you can have your cake and eat it too
and still keep it uh immutability kosher
and again the original list is unchanged
okay so years ago like I said a small
talk primer I was working in squeak and
after working for a while I was like
kind of frustrated about ad I was
talking about its nature and you know
it's ubiquitous in in the system it
seems you know as as fundamental as salt
on popcorn it's going to be hard to
change and lo and behold Alan can't
responded to my post which kind of blew
my mind was super exciting and he said
something that I never forget this is
paraphrase but a language is Select uh
selector namespace is its most precious
resource
because once you've done it it's out
there and those semantics are almost
immutable themselves
so we are judicious about naming and
semantics uh I want things to be
unambiguous I Co-op words from unrelated
domains a la grips to provide meaning
that is not overloaded okay so speaking
overloading what about this hand ax
thing
so what is a hit does anyone know what
hand X is
yes okay hand X's are cool Humanity's
first grade invention oldest Stone tools
that we know of you know a million a
million and a half years old uh second
only to fire really well I mean that we
know of you know it's hard to fossil
record it predates art
it predates language
uh one of the most beautifully designed
tools ever produced it is arguably at
least in the fossil record the first
tool that is Art Form and Function we
have these things that are called
discoid bi-face handxes which are
clearly unusable they will cut you if
you try to use it but people were making
them for fun and beauty
six hundred thousand years ago
uh there's some evidence that this is an
Evidence of hard-wiring that Humanity or
him Humanity doing tool making because
you have these disparate groups that
didn't have the same culture and yet
what are they making hand axes much like
birds or the same species making nests
that look alike who've never interacted
uh they've been continually improved
over the ages and obviously we get all
kinds of amazing stone tools as we move
through our life but most importantly it
is completely devoid of everything
overloading in the collections or
computer science space
there we go okay so let's talk about
implementation
you know this is all cute if in theory
but I was like oh man can I make it work
uh and you know
you never want to Define every method
you possibly can but you want it when
you need it when you need it you want it
to be right you don't want it to clash
so how can we do this in a dynamic
fashion where you don't have to do it by
hand and like I said the semantics are
so specific that it creates an
opportunity uh to have it done
automatically but for us to get in that
I'm going to give you a quick guide tour
through prototypal inheritance in
JavaScript okay so let's say we have
some
uh what are these called instances of
dictionaries and groups and
stuff okay they all inherit from a
common root a prototype that's
associated with the class oh my God I
use it so loosely in JavaScript
um a Constructor
and there's a hierarchy perhaps so uh
lists and dictionaries and not groups
inherent from collection and then they
heard from thing and finally get to a
root at the top
okay so again I I like to use kind again
over this bit of Constructor or type or
class because they're all so dang
overloaded what does it mean it's like
multimedia now okay
um so let's say I have a group
and I want to call index of on it so
this is what it's going to work it's
going to say okay group I want to I'm
group I want to call index up well first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
look inside myself do I have this
property no I don't okay let me look at
my prototype do I have it no I don't go
up to collection do I have it yes I do
fantastic there's the implementation I
will grab the implementation I will
execute the implementation on myself I'm
getting the value and I get two how
beautiful is that so that's how it works
it works its way up the tree okay so now
let's do another example so let's say
I have this list
that's composed from very strange
and I would like to go over strange and
fill it with Loop now I know this method
hasn't been made
so what are we going to Let's watch what
happens okay we go we're going to
execute over fill it goes to the list is
it there no it's not is it in the in the
Prototype no it's not it's not in the
collection it's not a thing so it goes
up to the root and the root is a proxy
and so the proxy is going to say oh okay
I got this property I don't know about
overfill and let's lazy does it first
does it match what is valid uh form and
let's say it does then we're going to
lazily install this method and so first
thing we have to do is parse the method
and that's I'm going to hand wave here
but we look at the keywords the locators
the qualifiers the target groups The
Operators there were no qualifiers or
Target groups but we have an implicit
grip for them which helps us compose a
method info object all the goodies we
need to know about this method we pass
this out and now I'm going to create a
new method from it there's some hand
waving some logic but this one gets sent
to a new Tuple setter templator
it's going to create this method and
it's going to return this method and now
it's going to put it right in the
hierarchy so it was like it was there
from the beginning
and now we're going to let that receiver
make use of this newly created
method
which it does
and we oh but here here it's actually
going to execute now
and what's interesting is
um
the way this is done you know thinking
about design patterns hand axes uses
deeply the templating method
um design pattern we have a template
method it may call other lazy template
methods it does through the process
itself again we have primitive methods
which they all must Implement themselves
and it may call other Primitives methods
as it's going through its process
okay but now we get this result and the
result is what we expect
strange has been replaced with loop loop
okay all right so
just Global Gestalt here like there's
only a few dozen Primitives that are
necessary to possibly compose thousands
of possible accessors and Setters that
meet
the uh semantics and vocabulary the
grammar of hand axis collections
okay so let's talk about future
directions
uh I need to finish the code it's
probably about 85 there uh this summer I
got to the point was like oh my God like
do I finish the code or do I have
something to talk about with you fine
people this is a labor of love so
off I go back to the drawing board as
soon as I leave uh
uh handling vacant spaces and
collections turns out to be making the
semantics exactly what they need to be
turns out to be shockingly persnickety
more unit tests of course
documentation I I really was using jdoc
a jsdoc for documentation but hand X
subverts the notion of how classes are
figured out by jstock I would love some
help with somebody who knows how to do
mods on that if anyone has experience
I'd love to switch to antler for the
grammar
we work in typescript now I'd love to
re-implement a typescript once the js1
is done but what's daunted me there is
the complex generic types and getting
types through a proxy if necessary I
have a way to do it without a proxy but
I prefer to use it
lastly well not lastly I'd like to make
a automatic visualizer for the language
the visual language that you saw earlier
uh and oh dang it it jumped ahead but I
would I would like to do um
uh time travel
um given the ability immutability
support Okay naming matters
my students will remember me always me
saying that time spent thinking about
naming is time well spent
give your thesaurus a kiss
uh spend time speaking to your average
and listen carefully to what you hear
you are not crazy and what I like to say
about this is
Humanity has been speaking for a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand maybe 300
000 years we've been writing for far
less and we've been coding for what uh a
hundred plus years at most
invariably I found that the language
used when speaking about your code is
far superior to that which you've
actually written so pay attention
um
yeah and so I like to say that you know
you write the code for the U of four
months from now it should be a love
letter it shouldn't just be good it
should be a love letter to your future
and your colleagues
uh and I've spent an inordinate amount
of time thinking about and talking to
collections so please forgive me
uh and that was my thank you
uh
please send me a note if you're
interested
um
all right I'm gonna have a drink of
water and like some questions
[Applause]